hey how's it going my name is Fanta and
it's with my great great pleasure for me
to be playing until dawn for you today
let's keep going
very interesting things are happening to
me because of your choices people have
died I don't know which is worse
actively triggering events that lead to
someone's death or passively allowing a
tragedy to occur because you couldn't
lift a goddamn finger to help someone
else their calm down Peter remember last
year ah thank you are you left your poor
sisters to die you did nothing to help
paralyzed by your own self-centered fear
while a wreath Brett was closing in oh
it's all about you Josh it's always all
about you
uh-huh okay has gone terribly wrong
Oh your sisters have deserted you
you're all alone that's cool
why did you hurt
Joshua why did you hurt them
they heard me they didn't hurt you
Joshua
not intentionally they made a stupid
mistake and a terrible tragedy befell
your sisters it did not intend for that
to happen it just did and they were
sorry at least until you subjected them
to your night of a horrific torture just
a game but it's a game that has driven
you to one of your own deepest fears
Georg isolation
did I say that I didn't fear and
isolation though oh how convenient
all right so if you have no idea what
just happened John I'm so pissed that he
died so pissed
what about that old guy not his head
right off another mic there's no key for
the cable car Josh he's got to have it
and what is all that it may have taken
him down to the mind the right thing
keep an eye on her I'll be back soon
yeah split up good idea Bravo you did it
okay so [ __ ] car - in a two hours
left we are really close bro oh [ __ ] so
we're back in the sanatorium where my
can spend a considerable amount of time
which is interesting
I like playing as Mike because there's
usually a lot of QuickTime events an
interesting [ __ ] happening I gotta say
though I looked up some of the actors on
IMDB and the girl that I think is the
oldest aw she's hatin pair yet or
whatever the girl from from heroes
she's they really made her a lot
better-looking in this game all right
she I'm not saying she's ugly but no all
right you guys are cheating you can't
just take the game and virtual reality
and give them amazing yoga pants and
then just do that no it's not how this
game works this is not why I'm playing
this now going back to sanatorium to get
the keys from this giant thing that
we're hiding from make sense
probably not why did we do it well the
world of cars for Mike I actually did
suspect a little bit that the guy that
Peter Stormare the guy in from the
beginning of this video was talking to
was it was the killer and it's
interesting how he was referring to in
the beginning act as like the game or
whatever so it actually made sense he
wasn't actually talking to us it's
really a clever really crawl at clemmer
I think okay
yeah who was the guy with the wolves
another yeah we remember how we found a
cigarette in the mines interesting very
interesting interesting I wonder how
much yeah you got to look around to find
like every [ __ ] clue it's also
interesting how you can't run in this
game technically like there's not many
games like third-person that you can't
run in okay what do we got here I'm not
sure exactly what I'm supposed to be
looking after so please be patient and
I'm sure we'll find it eventually so far
we haven't really gotten stuck so I
think I'll be okay perhaps going up the
stairs
alright I agree with you good call good
call doing great this is teamwork going
upstairs maybe the keys are upstairs
probably not what was that
mic should be like this is my hood by
now we have those exact same benches in
school that's kind of creepy how did he
know all right
don't see why not it's not like I have
anything else I can do and now we're
locked in
good thinking bro good thinking well
that's good you just had to push it you
try to you try to push it on the other
side it's not gonna work hello yes
please what do we got here insistent I
just need a pitchfork and a mob well
I'll take it we've got to be awkward to
hold that without two fingers yep but
that bat how did he know he was drenched
let's get the Shh sawed-off shotgun give
it to me give it to me
good enough good enough that [ __ ] are
you on about me right maybe now we can
shoot the door open isn't there like a
whole box of ammo over there I'd bring
that with me all right I try to find a
backpack or some [ __ ]
or at least fill my pockets with ammo
fit me maybe now we can go in here what
are you both saying should we try it
great been better boom met up
embarrassed
goddamnit I remind me of Chris who died
I'm so pissed Chris died cuz Chris
butterfly effected I had the dog bone I
have the dog bone oh it scared of me
from kicking it I'm sorry alright I
didn't want to kick it it's not my fault
here's a tunnel now this is weird
what is this case it leads to this utter
building all right all right all right
there's technically no [ __ ] way
that Josh would be in here I mean how
would the monster get in there locked
away never mind
you know what never mind creepy creepy
creepy this is very spooky so gorgeous
this game I can't get over how pretty it
is really love the use of angles it's
hard to pull up there goes nothing
how great that is
push it to the limit why don't you open
it first
[ __ ] oh my god this way ice oh God
down there come on
this is not our lucky day that's it this
has been don't be [ __ ] like I would all
takes place during one night that's a
really cool concept ooh it has a lot of
I feel like this game borrows a lot from
a lot of different horror games like
everybody was saw in general where the
decisions orion's me a Silent Hill in
love with the angles in third-person it
reminds me a lot of I have a rain of
course okay what do we got what are the
games let me know condemned it a little
bit actually the patient were first
admitted to Blackwood okay
I'm really I think there the next thing
is about what happened to Hanna and her
sister Beth we know Beth is dead for
sure but we don't know where Hanna Hanna
could be laughs still out there edge
that is more than a [ __ ] huh
something broke out of there like tags
oh [ __ ]
well it could have been the Windigo let
us out we're starving this is a clue why
not here stop the testing this is not
would they write that are the [ __ ]
wall so yeah that's my theory that it's
not really the Windigo it's just that
people who are testing on the sanitorium
I don't know that would make sense
this game has make sense so far which is
good oh did you see that did you were
you paying it are you paying attention
come on I need you here full screen
headphones right now oh you got it cool
great you're fast okay let's look over
here cuz I don't want to miss it
hello this is creepy
very nice and what else did we get
the b-wing
doctor's office that might be so this is
so creepy should we check in there I'm
gonna make sure I don't miss anything
okay could this be something about the
test subjects glad it works of course
this reminds me of that [ __ ] weird as
black-and-white horror film I don't know
if you've seen it it's like this woman
in a wheelchair just sitting super
oh god it's creepy Oh are they climbing
in walls yeah okay well that solves that
mystery they're not the [ __ ] Windigo
ready go
hey ready go I understood okay cool this
side and really help side she's just
like make a [ __ ] turn in the door I
think that was his sentence that
confirms our theory but let's keep
looking
it's still not entirely 100% positive
why the [ __ ] were here BAM whoa no this
is creepy Tamara Tamara BAM better
Oh Oh is this guy hey buddy I'm scary in
three two one go sorry oh no
okay what no no I want to read it pick
it up [ __ ] to who it may concern I like
how he's just chillin in the back hey
bones I your don't win baby
you're like my ball head they are dying
outside hear them screaming and crying
this hell is my only legacy Jefferson
Bragg thanks buddy chase mate
good place good temps there must have
been something else here did I miss
something
how [ __ ] gorgeous the game is not
fluid the camera movement is okay let's
keep looking
I cannot have been it maybe we missed
something else why am I doing this
like how we just gently put it back okay
well I thought they'd be more in here it
looked like a special area you know
oh nice 360 thank you okay what do we
got in here then some documents
give me like word sanatorium
confidential doesn't work with your
tongue okay good you know that guy looks
handsome what do we get
patient less handsome mr. Broadway hot
sauce Christmas cake this is [ __ ]
eyeball yeah but that [ __ ] did he just
say
bring it with you me okay
I guess this area is just for us to
figure out what happened like there's no
way you can walk through here and not
although some were more hit in the other
you know I'm saying
yeah fell let me broski okay well
there's nothing here it's not really
clear what we need let's try and go this
way
this is really creepy
oh god that's [ __ ] scary
my god they are so sexy they're turning
me on so much hello
oh good job no I'm not gonna shoot it
it's gonna alert oh god damn you're ugly
too ugly to live he's not gonna die I'm
not gonna [ __ ] up twice come on straight
ahead
come on [ __ ] your [ __ ] Oh Johnny
hey nice backflip Pratt oh god it's
disgusting
all right we did it
I have the flashlight bro don't worry
dumb scary in three no we have to run
back oh god no no no no Oh dad watch
close the door again close the door
[Music]
what's the [ __ ] plan here mate bro
you can't kill them oh we took the wrong
turn and that's why okay that's why
[Music]
that's kind of cool actually how they
did that I still have the machete
[Music]
alright we're doing good we're doing
good I feel confident that we can do
this oh stop one oh god another one
goddamn their creepy [ __ ] just got real
in this game you can read my [ __ ]
head oh let's say if I'm perfectly still
oh no oh oh
damnit
come on you son of a [ __ ] yeah come on
you son of a what what did we get out of
this or are you why are we here
why
damnit
what
what what em up what having a bat bat
bat boy how many [ __ ] ammo can fit
that one barrel that it's too bad
don't touch me bro
good time boys enough for me for all you
oh god I can't believe they set up a
scenario for every time you fail that's
awesome sorry I [ __ ] up there it's
really stressful so easy to press the
wrong [ __ ] one [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh my god I'm so focused yeah I'm
sweating man oh [ __ ]
oh god no [ __ ] me
just go just does go not good what is
that what do I do with this
oh god this is sick [ __ ] that I'm in Oh
bye
what the [ __ ] was that maybe they are
the Windigo I don't know anymore what
that [ __ ] was that I'm in Lock this door
now thank you I'll buy that sure was fun
I did that for no good reason absolutely
[ __ ] ever there is one more character
that I know there's one more character
like bad guy or good guy
but has not shown himself yet I know it
whew we did a breast that was intense
that was real [ __ ] intense I'm so
worried that I'm gonna [ __ ] up you know
it's so easy will you slip up once like
I did and the character is just dead and
you're like I want to replay that but
you can you have to replay the entire
[ __ ] game I'm just gonna go alright
just like Taylor Swift said I'm just
gonna go no wait I'm gonna I'm gonna
shake that's it alright I mixed him up
alright
oh god that's so scary
it sound like it ran right after me oh
god I didn't want to get out of here so
bad so [ __ ] bad please let me go
that's a frozen reference right there oh
my god
yeah boy berrykin everyone
Oh quick decisions huh God will the
silent and awkward because of it getting
real tired of you [ __ ] know
what you can
[Music]
yes yes yes oh yeah we did it Wow
that first guy I feel real God I'm not
gonna lie I feel really [ __ ] good
mate well that was fun
what's what's never ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever she I knew she was alive
that means only two characters side
should have been one god damn it I'm
pissed poor Jess she's my new BAE BAE
number one she's my boo after Mike B
died
no no more what is this so they just
told us that she's alive and that's all
you're gonna give us right now I'm
Ashley hmm hate Ashley I would have
killer stupid boyfriend died got damn
its portions what stupid ass stupid
[ __ ] it's not piss I'm pissed
I don't know what to tell you okay so we
are going after Mike no well his name I
forgot
Josh no David all Mike DJ tiesto sandal
alright it doesn't matter right this is
funky some downtown time
nice work of camera angle like nice
working drill the pants Mike must block
behind crap there's gotta be another way
in
what about this thing here wait hey what
about this
I mean should we try it
house not like we got a whole lot of
choices here I'm gonna grab this MA got
a hater
could she have died instead with the
Asians okay this is maybe the last place
I would want to be right now so he's
going first
okay that was not a question apparently
is that so bad
you think this is the tunnel to the
sanatorium of course it is where else
would it go your mom's [ __ ] maybe
[ __ ] you and your attitude I wouldn't go
down there
not without any way of defending myself
I just be like sorry guys Mike I made a
mistake it's not my [ __ ] fault
it's like item maybe he lives or maybe
we die all right
hey um what why close this right ah I
mean what if something's following us
yes fine close it but we gotta keep
moving
just catch up please
yeah [ __ ] going down
yes actually this is their calling
oh god something's gonna happen
Jesus Christ where do they go
of course they're gone how [ __ ]
can't wait to [ __ ] seconds Jesus
Christ no I see them their lights are
there
who's there anybody mrs. strange
I would rejoin the group
thank you below I'm not an idiot
I played enough horror games movies - no
way that that is a trap I ain't falling
- okay guys
you guys over here great go ahead we did
this all right
like when Felix wears that stupid
headband I'm glad you're saying mmm look
look there Wow all right butters house
we're never gonna make it up there I
think I can I think I can do it it's
like a rock wall I'm gonna keep going
Mike good luck okay well that settles
that
okay that was a weird [ __ ] scene who
are we playing us now Jessica probably
was she the one calling for help maybe
oh god I didn't think about that
No
is she gonna be dead now not spiders man
anything but the spiders please I don't
like them they're scary yoga pants yoga
like how y'all pants like some holy [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ] spider calm down woman
she cray-cray couldn't they have waited
for her climb up just to make sure like
she made it I would have done that no I
I did it I press the button alright
where we go drop down
why oh [ __ ] me no way
[ __ ] - man [ __ ] this oh okay sure no
problem a big deal
Oh God big deal big deal big deal sorry
I changed my mind
hello
Oh God
we can still save Josh I think there's
still hope for Joshy Jude finally this
game has 256 endings so feel free to
spoil me one of them although I wonder
how different they are if you take like
each character dying you get a lot of
different combinations right there so
let's see yes it's like that the problem
would have it rain way oh god that I had
one big [ __ ] plot twist that was a
really good plot twist though but
everyone loves to spoil the plot twists
and I think it would have been
interesting if I'm not gonna spoil it
but it would have been interesting if
like the choices of the game there's no
way to change the plot twist that's the
thing I think a lot of people get pissed
about alright that conversation probably
didn't mean anything to you unless you
knew it the game alright I'm sorry
we averaged seven
I can't aim down oh you tricked me oh
you lost your [ __ ] head
holy [ __ ] my stomach can't handle this
this is too much stress for one day -
fine all right just alive or stark yeah
anyway thanks for the warning I think I
got it hahaha let's find a way down
where this [ __ ] lives okay no you know
I will keep playing I'm gonna keep
playing it's a bit weird to like keep an
episode going here but we're just gonna
have to do it can't believe he died I
don't know what I did wrong there cuz
like there was no QTEs there was nothing
to click he just died cable car Josh
he's got a have it he's gone
we're too late it may have taken him
down to the mine
I like always heaven just fell off from
unless scratch and the Asian lady got
scratched and it just lit her is French
oh it's that thing that happened one
minute ago thank you game
whoa let's find a way down to where this
[ __ ] lives as much as I like that even
if you [ __ ] up that's it you can't go
back I kind of wish it wasn't episodes
this game because that's how they split
it up anyway right one hour all right so
this is the last one you don't look too
good Peter
neither does Josh can you forgive a
friend for doing such a shitty thing you
said it so I'm gonna leave you now Josh
it's time you learned very small to be
afraid of that can be trapped up by the
unhinged imagination of a self-indulgent
spoiled little brat you had so many
people you don't cares about you
we're willing to help but at every turn
you choose to push them away
oh but it sounds why eat some mean no
you won't be long long deep breaths
joy
a reaction gonna play as Josh that would
be pretty interesting
oh it's a sister sauna a methane is
being it's probably just in his head you
can't help but sympathize a little bit
for Josh you leave okay I trust you I
trust you I trust you
Wickham my way downtown walking fast
faces pass in them oh you're all alone
down there I'm just gonna go with
everything and I write that door
No you're with us now family why don't
you save us Josh why did you want us to
job
[Music]
man the sisters are [ __ ] what is
this
[Music]
that [ __ ] is going on probably I'm not
sure the final episode tomorrow thank
you both so much for making it this far
and being patient with me I'm sorry I
can't make these longer but that's it
for now I'll see you tomorrow
and we'll finish this together brofist